hey guys Pete here going to talk about
some Game of Thrones history today from
what I think is one of the most
interesting events that comes up several
times in the song and Ice and Fire books
the Tony at Harrenhal if you're a show
only fan you might wonder why is this
important there are a few reasons one at
the end of season six we just had
confirmation that Jon Snow's parents are
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark his
father crowned his mother the queen of
love and beauty at the tourney instead
of his own wife and that basically led
to Robert's rebellion - Danny's father
traveled to the tourney of Harrenhal
because he feared that her brother
Rhaegar was plotting against him in
three a confirmed filming location for
an action scene in season seven is the
ruins of a Roman city in Spain and when
I first saw the pictures the first thing
that came to mind was that we were going
to get a Harrenhal flashback I know
Spain isn't really Riverland ish per se
but the structure seemed like a good
place for some jousting and they can do
quite a bit with CGI effects as far as
the background goes so we'll just have
to see what happens I'm probably wrong
about this but my fingers are crossed
either way and hey the TV show should
really cover this because it's essential
in relations in relation to John's
parentage and basically all the events
that we know of from the show if that
doesn't hook you in just think about the
fact that there if there was no tourney
at Harrenhal none of what happens in the
TV show Game of Thrones would have ever
happened the Targaryen smite still be on
the throne which means no King Robert
who would have never married Cersei and
so on so it's important there's a lot of
talk about so I will be breaking this
video up in two parts in the first video
I'm going to talk about what we know
history wise from the book series and
from the world of Ice and Fire and part
two will likely be about the tourney
itself and mirrors mirror Reed's account
of the tourney that she heard from her
father will likely be a video of its own
before we get into any of that we need
contacts so let's jump right into it so
in a Song of Ice and Fire we first hear
about the tourney at Harrenhal in the
very first book a game of Thrones one
that is locked up in the black cells
beneath the red keep Ned was 18 when he
attended the tourney with his brothers
and sister and still has vivid memories
of it in the Storm of Swords Jaime
remembers the tournament when he passes
through Harrenhal
a captive of the brave companions in the
show think of when he rescued Brianne
from the bear pit after getting a sword
hand cut off and later in that same book
mirror retells brand story about the
about the tourney as they are traveling
north before he reveals his identity to
her sir Barristan Selmy tells Danny
about how her brother Rhaegar had won
the tournament later in a dance of
dragons sir Barristan has another memory
of the tourney and how he was unseated
by Rhaegar in the final child in a world
of Ice and Fire we get a lot more
details about the tourney and the
politics surrounding it in King Aerys
the second chapter and the section on
the year of the fall spring what we know
from all of this is that Tony was home
to anyone Acey at Harrenhal which is in
the Riverlands it is also known as Lord
once great tournament since Lord Walter
went put the tournament on to celebrate
his maiden daughter's name day 281 see
AC is also known as the year of the fall
spring that's because spring seemed like
it was coming and then winter ended up
just coming back the tournament lasted
for ten days and is remembered as the
greatest of its time the main reason
being that the prizes Lord whent put up
or so large for comparison Tywin
Lannister held a big Tony to celebrate
King Harris's rule in its tenth year and
whence prizes were for three times what
Tywin offered at a time when he was
actually handed the king such large
prizes which were announced the year
before the actual tournament pretty much
everyone who was able to make it came to
Harrenhal some people saw this as Lord
whent showing off his wealth while
trying to outdo the Kings hand but at
the same time a lot of people didn't
believe he could afford it for them this
must have meant there was a secret
backer working behind the scenes in this
scenario the most likely candidate would
be Rhaegar Targaryen who had no shortage
of gold and who may have been looking to
bring all the Lords of the major houses
of Westeros together to discuss what
could be done about his father the Mad
King who at this point was definitely
spiraling into madness
why would Rhaegar want to do this well
four years before the tourney King Aerys
had traveled to dusk and nail to over a
dispute with the Lord their over taxes
it's a long story but in the end it
turned out to be a trap and Aerys was
taken hostage it was up to the Kings
hand Tywin Lannister to bring troops and
free
King when he arrived and surrounded the
castle he got word from the people
inside that if there was any sign that
they were going to try to breach the
walls the king would be murdered on the
spot so in the end
sir Barristan came up with this crazy
plan and he was able to slip in to the
castle and free Aerys but the King never
recovered from the ordeal it created a
rift between Aerys and Tywin who had
been friends since childhood and you
know basically split them up and they
would never you know Aerys especially
would never trust Tywin again after dusk
endale the King refused to leave the Red
Keep and he like stopped cutting his
hair and his fingernails and became
completely paranoid that everyone was
out to get him so there were real
questions about whether the King was
still capable of ruling the realm and
his um you know his relationship with
Rhaegar was strained when Rhaegar
married Elia Martell of Dorne there were
no other sisters for him to marry a
guy's his father and other targets had
in the past they ended up deciding to
live at Dragonstone instead of King's
Landing so when they had their first
child
Rhaenys you know they came back to the
red key to present the child to the king
and the Queen and the king actually
refused to hold her and what he said was
that you know the baby smelled Dornish
that was his excuse for not one in the
whole Rhaegar baby after that incident
you know the relationship became more
distance and this was you know pretty
much at or around the same time the Tony
was playing into ADAC
the freghar was behind playing in the
tournament he would have guessed that he
could be you know he could be able to
bring all these Lords together without
his father actually being there after
all
Arras hadn't left the red keep for the
better part of four years at this point
this probably would have worked but
heiresses new master of whisperers Varys
the spider convinced the king that
Rhaegar was behind the tourney and was
fighting to have him removed as king by
calling a Great Council in Harrenhal
since we were pretty familiar with Varys
and his ability to know what's going on
I think this is a clue that it's likely
a terrace was right to listen to him and
attend the Tony after all so the
politics basically boiled down to this
everyone knew that Aerys was crazy he
was known for burning people that pissed
him off with wildfire but even so not
everyone wanted him
from the throat as cruel as he was he
was also known to be generous to those
who pleased him in some people
especially the Lord's that were on his
small council regaining wealth and lands
while Hebrew rule on the other hand
there were plenty of people who just
wanted him gone and so there were
basically two groups vying for power the
group that was behind the Mad King and
the group that was behind a son Rhaegar
to put it into perspective the potential
height going on in Westeros around this
twenty check out this excerpt from the
world of Ice and Fire
many tales have grown up around Lord
Wentz tournament tales of plots and
conspiracies betrayals and rebellions
infidelities and as Ignatians secrets
and mysteries
almost all of it conjecture the truth is
known only to a few some of whom have
long passed beyond this mortal veil and
must forever hold their tongue in
writing of this fateful gathering
therefore the the conscientious scholar
must take care to separate fact from
fancy to draw a sharp line between what
is known and what is simply suspected
believed or rumor so let's look at what
is known as mentioned the Tony was held
in 281 AC and offered massive prizes it
was spread out over a 10-day period with
five days with jousting a seven sided
melee various other contests for archery
axe throwing a horse race plus a
tournament of singers and a mummers show
there's no hard evidence that Rhaegar
was behind the tournament and its
purpose was to gather support from you
know the other houses room his father
but many including the members of the
King's small Council believe this to be
the case they went as far as to urge the
king to forbid the tournament or
outlawed all tournaments so that it
wouldn't happen King Aerys knew that the
common people of his realm loved Tony so
and decided to attend in the end anyways
grand maester pycelle claims that the
king was hoping to use the event to help
him win back the love of his people the
large prizes drew competitors and Lords
from throughout the Seven Kingdoms and
even more were inspired to make the
journey when they heard the king would
be in attendance however most people
were shocked when they actually saw the
king and how much he had visibly
declined in health
remember he hadn't had his hair or nails
cut for like four years we don't know
that Rhaegar was behind it but we do
know that he
had the opportunity to be the one behind
it Lord Wentz brother was sir Oswald
when who was a member of the Kingsguard
it wouldn't have been that difficult for
the Prince to use sir Oswald as his
liaison with Lord Walter White pretty
much everyone was there so I'll just
emphasize some of the characters that
non book readers will know from the show
so in attendance we had King Aerys a
second the Mad King we saw him in brands
vision during season six Robert
Baratheon eventually you know he became
King Robert after his rebellion that
basically started at this Tory mace
tyrell he was Marjorie and lorises
father he ended up dying when Cersei
destroyed the great Sept in the TV show
Jon Arryn who served as King Robert's
hand and he was close friends with Ned
from their childhood his death and the
information he found out about the
legitimacy of Circe's children with
Robert set in motion the Game of Thrones
as we know it the Crown Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen and his wife Elia Martell
we've talked about Rhaegar and what his
motivations might have been and we'll
talk a lot more about what happens in
the next video Prince Oberyn Martell he
came to King left King's Landing for
Joffrey's wedding in the show and ended
up being Tyrians champion in the trial
by combat against the mountain he did
that because he wanted to avenge the
death of his sister Elia who was married
to Rhaegar but in the end he ends up
being killed Arthur Dayne in the show we
see him defending the tower of joy and
you know he's beating Ned Holland Reid
kills him from behind he's also known as
the sword of the morning and is
considered one of the greatest nights in
the Seven Kingdoms you know in his
lifetime ashara dayne she was Arthur
Dayne sister Jo white Watchers might not
know who she is but she is an important
character so they will probably talk
about her some more Barristan Selmy a
member of the Kingsguard who is well
respected by all King Joffrey ends up
removing him as one of the white cloaks
because he's old and Joffrey wanted the
Hound on the Kingsguard
after that Barristan travels to Essos
finds Daenerys and serves her until he's
killed by the sons of the harpy Jaime
Lannister King Aerys actually makes him
a member of the Kingsguard during the
opening ceremony of the tourney and he
did that to put Lord Tywin in its place
essentially taking his heir from him
we'll talk about that part more later
Brandon stark meds
brother before the tournament Brandon
had been betrothed to Kaitlyn thali who
eventually marries Ned and becomes
Catelyn Stark Eddard Stark or Ned he was
18 at the time of this tawny Benjen
stark Ned's younger brother we know him
from the early seasons of the TV show as
a member of the Nights Watch Lyanna
stark Ned's sister who we note who we
now know as Jon Snow's mother on the TV
show Helen Reid
he's Jojen and Meera father he's really
interesting a mysterious character we
have only seen on the show in that one
tower of joy scene and that's those are
the major players I mean there's a
million other people there but you won't
know who they are and these are the ones
that are you know that we'll talk about
the most I guess so this should set the
stage with the story motivations and
working of the different players before
the tourney at Harrenhal
in part two we'll talk about the events
of the day and how things would never be
the same in the Seven Kingdoms
after the tournament's conclusion let me
know in the comments if you have any
questions from this video or anything
you want me to clarify in the future
videos in part three we'll dig into the
mystery night denied the Laughing tree
so if you have any questions about that
go ahead and post them and please like
the video if you found it interesting
and subscribe to my channel for you know
so you can see all my new videos as soon
as they come out right now I'm working
on finishing up the script for my second
part of the Queen Cersei series and then
so I'll put that out and then I'll put
part two of this series up right after I
soon as I can
so thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon